today on the anime zone a review of
sword art online and anime about a group
of players trapped in a virtual reality
MMORPG trying to escape
it has romance it has adventure it has
mystery but best of all it has the epic
boss battles don't let up your tax
everyone
Rajon Wednesday this is it guys who's
taking the final shot [ __ ] my life
the world of MMORPGs confuse me
I've never properly got into them
personally but as an outsider looking in
it just seems like a massive time spongy
which will probably play as some ugly
mother [ __ ] mutant man dwarf if
you're a male or some sex God elf
complete with big tits if you want to
pretend you're a female running around
in a virtual ward full of other big tits
spending days on end raising an
arbitrary number that represents your
strength which probably rises in
negative correlation to your sex life
but what the hell do I know
nevertheless the genres gained massive
popularity in both the east and west I
can only be topped worldwide the day
someone decides to make gears of halo
modern black ops 7 featuring nazi
zombies that dance Gangnam style so [ __ ]
comes no surprise to anyone that the
anime has gained most popularity and of
course controversy in 2012 is the RPG
based anime sword art online the story
starts off introducing the newest MMO
RPG to hit the market sword art online a
game so great that geeks worldwide have
apparently been tossing themselves silly
in glee and anticipation while the rest
of the world is probably out there
having sex on its launch day everything
seems to be going swimmingly for
everyone the world looks gorgeous and
the game plays every bit as great as is
hyped up to be that is until the game's
creator Kayaba Akihiko gathers all plays
in one place to reveal a catch firstly
all plays advertiser change to look like
their reward bodies good-looking men
become fat geeks good-looking ladies
become fat geeks fat geeks become fat
geeks and underage girls become FBI
agents secondly all players are now
trapped in the game with no way out
until they complete it everyone must
live breathe and play the world of sword
art online until someone beats all 100
flaws of it and here's the stinger if
you die in the game it will be the end
of your life online or to put it in
words everyone once that people die if
they are killed the story is told
through the eyes of our main protagonist
canítö one of the original beta testers
in the game who in real life is a super
hacker that's been obsessed with
spending every waking hour trapped
inside playing video games ever since a
young age
aka he's a [ __ ] loser at least he
should be if he didn't attract every
female within a 10-mile in-game radius
yes it's pretty much established at the
female plays are somewhat rare in the
game and yet the main character seems
like a bonafide chick magnet with a
variety of different girls all in
different shapes and boob sizes lining
up so he can have a pic of which
stereotype he wants other important
characters include asana the main
female lead introduces a mysterious
badass player that turns out to be a
generic syndra who is completely useless
without her boyfriend
Sega who is introduced later on it gets
plenty of development by which I mean
she has massive breasts who is
completely useless without her boyfriend
and the rest of the harem bait only gets
about one episode of screen time anyway
but it's enough to establish that
they're completely useless without their
[ __ ] boyfriend but I'll touch that
subject later now with my previous
reaction videos there might be some
confusion as to what I actually thought
about the show
so obviously that dress right now did I
think sword art online was good oh kinda
there are some things that the show does
really well and one of them is most
certainly the action if anyone pictures
has proved something to me after
watching this and birdie the mighty
decode is that they know how to do that
action and I know how to do it
absolutely gorgeously the highlights in
Sao is undoubtedly the action scenes and
this especially shines during every
single boss battle we see the boss
battles were glorious spectacle that
never failed to drop my jaw right down
to the floor and gave me aa static
thrill of the hours spent fighting my
own boss battles as a kid playing some
grand video game combine this with a
soundtrack made by yuuki cadre who if
you can't remember did the soundtrack to
fade zero and you'll find yourself
having eyes and ear Gazans during the
fantastically done high points of the
show even if the choir sounds like
they're singing about gaming snacks
yes the action of music are definitely
the highlights of the show in addition
to the beach for art that really made
the stunning in-game setting stand out
and made you feel like you wanted to be
a part of this game unfortunately the
same cannot be said about the story in
characters which have enough individual
problems to fill up a Britannica
encyclopedia set though to be honest
just about every problem I have can be
summed up in basically one line it [ __ ]
joking joking in all seriousness the
show takes itself way too seriously
so much so that I'm pretty sure ripped
off some iconic scenes from end of
Evangelion and berserk because
apparently is just as serious as those
other two shows yes the biggest feeling
I got from the series was that he was
trying to set itself up as an epic
action adventure tale set in a vast
unexplored online virtual world where it
just really felt like a group of [ __ ]
pissing about in a video game the
characters themselves aren't nearly as
developed as they pretend to be since
the amount of characterization I got
after 25 episodes of following Kirito is
that he's some awesome badass because he
wears black clothes and he's really good
at video games spends most of his time
trying to be the lone antihero and picks
up chicks long the way like they're
[ __ ] Pokemon he's the ultimate
wish-fulfillment character since he's
stupidly overpowered for unexplained
reasons and anything remotely Regina
shaped becomes completely reliant on him
perfectly encapsulated in this scene
here when he takes on seven full-grown
[ __ ] to protect what looks like
a five-year-old and becomes the first
person ever to win a fight by apparently
standing people into submission ass in
this character for all the potential she
showed in a badass introduction just
turned out to be a generic cinder a that
doesn't develop any deeper than that
her romance would create I feel so for
some generic it feels like it was
written by a teenager who was just
guessing at how romances work guy meets
girl they kind of know each other spend
some time together she acts like she
doesn't like him [ __ ] she cooks for
him suddenly she likes him they spend a
few more days together and then they
just decide to get married what the
whole thing was just handled so lazily
and developed a ridiculously unnatural
paste leaving Larson there's nothing
more than just a plot device by the end
as for the story well the biggest draw
for the show is of course the great way
the series setup is premise the first
three episodes of the show were great
setting up the intriguing premise
perfectly that hinted at an epic quest
to clear the game that would take a hell
of a lot of work sacrifice and hardship
that could possibly lead to some higher
purpose it instantly drew you in and
made you want to see more this world and
how things would develop unfortunately
from there never really built on a tonne
of potential set in early
episodes by instead deciding to focus on
a soiree of side stories that hardly
ever focus on the main goal while
constantly having time skips as if half
the show's set in the hyperbolic time
chamber one moment it was an
action-adventure and a next minute it
was CSI [ __ ] Warcraft it didn't have
any focus which is a shame cuz if the
plot did decide to go in the direction
of the early episodes it could have been
a great anime even with these problems
though the first half was still an
enjoyable look into a real-life gaming
environment and it was very interesting
to see the psychological implications of
actually creating a society in a virtual
world
each episode managed to build on a new
aspect of the game and just seeing how
core game mechanics was integrated into
our daily lives led to a very intriguing
setting that never failed to grab my
interest however the shoddy writing
becomes completely evident in the second
half of the show when it takes a
nosedive so spectacular it was Olympic
medal worthy with us fully too much the
great action is still there but the
story takes a turn which makes to lose
all sense of purpose while ironically
managing to make you feel like you're
watching a video game played by some
pretentious idiots taking it 10,000
times too seriously all feeling of
urgency is lost and it's hard to feel
for characters when the entire story arc
is driven by romance that was a
dribbling mess in the first place a
little sister character is introduced
who's not really a sister wink-wink
along with a new villain who seems about
as threatening as a cam butterfly
probably because that's exactly what he
looks like not helped by the fact that
he's a middle-aged man who just happens
to scream like a fifteen-year-old girl
the writing also takes a backseat as our
multiple moments where the show
disregards its own in-game rules in
favor of Dex Magna writing to either
advance the plot or make her Ito look
like a badass leaving some a spool so
big it probably left the show with an
anus the size of the Grand Canyon the
show has the exact opposite problem that
high school the dead had by trying to be
something that he was not and if it
wasn't taking itself too seriously I
probably would be a lot less harsh in it
because there is a lot of fun to be had
here despite all of this though it has
still become by far the most popular
anime of 2012 it's no surprise how there
was such a huge popularity spike since
I'm pretty sure becoming the most badass
character stuck in the ultimate video
game with hordes of females chasing
after you is the secret wish of every
gamer out there but bad writing a shoddy
characters aside the show was definitely
entertaining particularly if you're a
gamer there's a certain sense of
satisfaction in seeing all these gaming
terms being thrown around and raising
the stakes up to a game that looks
genuinely fun to play because as many
criticisms as a hat I was never once
bored while watching the show even if
part of the entertainment will see the
amount of stupid being radiated in later
episodes the action and his best was
able to make me forget about the story
and characters for a brief period the
setting makes it the perfect gateway
anime for newbies and they obviously
know their target audience well enough
to execute this premise so much so that
I would say that if you like video games
especially if you like MMORPGs you will
probably like this in one way or another
overall sword art line is a solid show
that has an interesting premise with
great animation and music but really
fails when it comes to the characters
and plot at the very least it's an
entertaining watch and does well to
explore the concept of actually living
in a high stakes game but takes itself
far too seriously and if you want any
kind of a joyfulness anime it's probably
best to watch it without thinking too
much it's not as good as the fanboys
praise it to be but it's not as bad as
the haters claim it to be either
currently sword art online is yet to
have a DVD or blu-ray release but is
available for streaming on crunchyroll
you can also go to crunchyroll.com slash
the anime zone for free fortnight of
premium membership and if there's one
thing gamers should take from this
series is that you shouldn't take your
gaming life too seriously all it ever
boils down to is a bunch of numbers and
your online life doesn't have to be
ruled by some arbitrary numbers that
have no real meaning on a topic how
about subscribing to me so I can reach
sixty thousand subs
Kirito me bang all the chicks poquito no
no whoo no need to bow
would you like young one yeah slap me
upside the head and call me Carrie still